[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host definition aka your friendly
neighborhood spoiler man and if like me
is still reeling from the phase four
announcement panel then you in for a
real treat
Marvel have released a whole host of
details about their upcoming spinoff
series what if and throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the show's cast
release state and giving my thoughts on
what we could see in it there will be
heavy spoilers here so if you don't want
to know anything about the upcoming
series that I highly recommend that you
turn off now without the way I just want
to give a huge thank you for clicking
this video now let's get into my
breakdown of Marvel's what if okay so
firstly I thought I'd give a brief
overview of the what-if series and
discuss what exactly it is those who are
fans of Marvel Comics will be familiar
with yes thetic and they have been
countless what if graphic novels
released over the company's long
enriched publishing history the series
takes a key moment in Marvel history and
subverts it slightly to show what the
outcome could have been like for the arc
had it gone another way my favorite
example of this is in the Civil War
storyline in which Captain America and
Iron Man actually form a truce and this
cap is never kill and yeah I don't spoil
too much but it's a brilliant arc
they're not all happy endings though and
in the case of Avengers vs. x-men
sometimes these turns aren't necessarily
for the best it's a safe assumption to
make then that the what-if series will
focus on key events in the MCU and show
what could have happened in an alternate
timeline the show will be narrated by
Jeffrey Wright who is making his MCU
debut as The Watcher and he will be
taking us from location to location and
demonstrating how even the most minor
change can have huge consequences
the first scenario that we have
confirmed is the Peggy Carter spin-off
which involves caps old flame taking the
Super Soldier Serum instead of the
star-spangled man with a plan which by
the way is a song that absolutely loved
smash that like button if you love this
song to Disney have done an incredible
job of reuniting the cast once more and
this star-studded lineup is probably
worth going back in time for featuring
the voices of Hayley Atwell Dominic
Cooper Stanley Tucci neal mcdonough
Bastien Stan and Toby Jones it looks
like this piece will be set
predominantly in World War 2 and show
Peggy going head-to-head with Hydra with
Bucky Howard Stark in the Howlin
commandoes at his side I can see this
playing out a lot differently with her
probably not going into the ice at the
end and therefore not being around to
help out the Avengers further down the
line
Bucky probably won't become the Winter
Soldier and it's a whole host of
potential to massively alter the
universe especially because this was its
starting block the most interesting
thing about this lineup is that Chris
Evans is nowhere to be seen and it's
crazy to think how different that the
MCU would be if Stanley Tucci's
character had not saved him at the
recruitment office overall I'm really
looking forward to this and I think it's
an inspired choice that the show is
going back to square one to show us all
of the different possibilities that
could be ahead if you're a fan of the
aging Carter TV show then you know that
Peggy packs a punch you already and this
could be an amazing Elseworlds story to
tell the next scenario I think will be
heavily focused on the Guardians
timeline and it could even tie into
endgame this is a big moment in that
movie where Rhodey knocks out Peter
quill and thus creates an alternate
timeline in which he would never get the
power stone and thus the Guardians would
never be formed and Ronan would probably
go on to become that universes Thanos
looking at the cast list which is made
up of Thanos nebula Koroth taser face
yes
taser face and yondu it appears that
this spin-off could even display what
would have happened if quill had never
betrayed you on you and he had have
handed over the power stones
straightaway to the mad Titan this would
have meant that the snap would have
happened sooner probably at a time when
the Avengers were ill-equipped to deal
with Thanos and there's a wealth of
potential here I mean who doesn't want
to see the big purple grimace looking
guy return to Marvel I know I definitely
do and I think this could make for an
incredible spinoff we're also getting
the return of chadwick boseman and
Michael B Jordan who of course went
head-to-head in black panther what if
stories tend to show what would have
happened had the losing side won I can
definitely see this playing out with
kill manga as the big day and having the
forces of what can to take
of the world instead of hiding in the
shadows it's definitely going to be an
interesting choice and may even have the
Avengers going head to head with killed
manga to bring an end to his reign of
terror which yeah
will be great especially if Tony doesn't
have access to nanotechnology and you
could just get wiped out by work under
the next what if story judging by the
cast list will probably change up the
events of Thor Ragnarok and it's
refreshing to see Mark Ruffalo Jeff
Goldblum Natalie Portman Tom Hiddleston
Taika Waititi and Chris Hemsworth in the
lineup so what could this be about well
it's difficult to say but I think that
we could actually get all out version of
Planet Hulk with the big Green Giant
maybe killing the door in their face off
and then going on to take over the
planet similar to the graphic novel Korg
was a big part of the source material so
it's nice to see that he's making a
return to the absence of Thor could make
Loki seek out Jane Foster and we could
see her becoming the new god of thunder
faster than we thought with his change
in dynamics there's a lot of potential
here and I'm really excited to see the
return of the Grand Master the final
scenario looks like it's going to be
focusing on an Avengers team-up without
all the big names we have Jeremy Renner
Paul Rudd samuel l.jackson and Michael
Douglas returning and due to this cast I
actually think that it will take place
just after Civil War with potentially
cap and Iron Man killing one another in
their battle at the end of the film this
would force fury to scramble together
the last of the heroes and as all these
characters were absent in infinity war
this episode could center around what
would have happened if they'd went
head-to-head with Thanos I'm just gonna
stop you right there I know you're
typing ant-man flies up thanasis but but
I'm just gonna stop you
please don't get my video demonetized
with your nasty nasty comments anyway
what if is due to release in the summer
of 2021 and I'm massively hyped for it
this looks like an amazing show and I
can't wait to see what other potential
timelines it explores obviously I'd love
to hear your thoughts on what if and if
you're excited as I am
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video then please give it a
thumbs up and make sure you check out my
full breakdown of all the comfirm phase
5 yes phase 5 movies that we currently
have in development we break down all of
the major announcements so it's
definitely worth checking out if you
want
more I'll leave that linked at the end
and hopefully I'll see you over there
after this if you want to come talk to
me directly or just want to see my
general thoughts of movies TV shows and
games that make sure you follow me on
twitter at definition whitey i also just
want to let you know that we're giving
away a free copy of a vengeance endgame
on blu-ray to one lucky winner and all
you have to do is like this video make
sure that you subscribe to the channel
and leave your thoughts on the movie in
the comments section below
but when it'll be chosen at random on
August the 10th and the blu-ray will be
shipped out from then to ever get
surprised so best of luck to everyone
who takes part this is a channel for
people who are super into superheroes so
if that's the kind of thing you like hit
subscribe thanks again for taking the
time to watch this I've been definition
you've been the best and I'll see you
next time take care peace
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]